La suma de tres enteros consecutivos impares es 231.
¿Cuál es el más grande de estos enteros?
Y bueno, pensemos un poco en este problema.
Si yo digo que "x" es el entero más pequeño
de estos tres enteros consecutivos,
entonces lo voy a escribir aquí. "x" es el más pequeño de estos enteros consecutivos impares.
Y con esto entonces,
¿cuál es el siguiente entero impar?
No sé, imagínate que "x" vale 3, si "x"
vale 3, el siguiente entero impar sería 5
y el siguiente sería 7 y el siguiente sería
9 y así nos podríamos seguir y seguir y seguir...
Date cuenta que lo único que estoy haciendo
es sumando 2 así que si "x" es el más pequeño
de estos enteros impares, "x" más 2 sería
el consecutivo entero impar de "x" y bueno,
ya que tenemos que estos son enteros, este
es entero también, entonces el siguiente
entero impar sería "x" más 2 más 2, es decir, "x" más 4, "x" más 4 va a ser el más grande de estos
enteros impares o dicho de otra manera el consecutivo de estos enteros impares de "x" más 2.
Fíjate que de 3 a 7 sumamos 4 ó de 5 a 9
sumamos 4
y entonces, me dicen que la suma de estos tres consecutivos enteros impares es 231,
es decir, que la suma de "x" más "x" más 2 más "x" más 4, la suma de estos tres, me tiene que dar 231,
vamos a anotarlo porque esto es muy importante.
"x" más "x" más 2 más "x" más 4
esto tiene que ser igual a 231 y me preguntan,
¿cuál es el mayor de estos enteros?
Pues para esto sería muy bueno saber cual es el valor de "x" dada esta ecuación de primer grado.
Y para esto voy a sumar las "x", "x" más
"x" más "x" es "3x"
y por otra parte tengo 2 más 4 lo cual es 6... 2 más 4 es 6 y esto tiene que ser igual a 231...
esto es igual a 231...
y ahora de aquí ya tengo una ecuación muy
fácil de resolver para "x".
Lo primero que voy a hacer es restar 6 de
ambos lados de la ecuación, así que -6 aquí,
-6 acá y me queda "3x" porque estos dos se
van, "3x" es igual a 231 menos 6...
231 menos 6, esto es lo mismo que 225.
225, ¡perfecto!
"3x" es igual a 225 y ahora para obtener el
valor de "x" lo que voy a hacer es dividir
ambos lados de esta ecuación entre 3,
entonces 3 entre 3 se van y me queda
solamente que "x" es igual a, ¡wow!
225 entre 3.
Y ahora sí, "x" es igual a 225 entre 3.
Vamos a hacer esta división por acá, 225 entre 3...
Primero, 3 cabe en 22, 7 veces, 7 por 3 es
21 entonces 22 menos 21 me da 1,
solamente uno y bajo el 5 y después me queda 15 entre
3 lo cual es 5, eso está muy fácil,
5 por 3 es 15, entonces 15 menos 15 me da 0 y es una división exacta, por lo tanto, "x" vale 75.
El entero impar más chico de esos 3 es 75,
"x" vale 75 y una vez que ya sabemos cuanto
vale "x", entonces el siguiente entero impar
consecutivo a 75 pues va a ser 77,
ya tenemos el segundo y por último, el más grande de
estos enteros impares consecutivo a 77
es "x" más 4, lo cual es 79.
Y ya con esto tengo la respuesta.
¿Cuál es el entero más grande?
Pues la respuesta va a ser 79, 79 y sería muy bueno verificar que en efecto me diera la suma de estos 3, 231.
Así que 75 más...
es más, déjame ponerlo mejor de esta manera...
75, 77, 79 y vamos a sumarlos todos.
5 más 7 es 12, más 9 es 21 y llevamos 2,
2 más 7 es 9, 9 más 7 es 16, 16 más 7 es 23, ¡perfecto!
Entonces la suma de estos 3 enteros impares
y consecutivos es 231,
date cuenta que estos tres son enteros, son impares y son consecutivos y el más grande de estos es 79.